nature can be deadly man-eating beats
will kill in a heartbeat and the largest
land carnivore of them all is the bear
which is why you should never do this
the claws on that day holy macaroni
this bear could bite this man in half if
he wants to why isn't the bear attacking
him great question Matt to get the
answer we snatched Jim from the jaws of
death and join him and his wife Susan at
the orphaned Wildlife Center in New York
State
these are bears that would have never
made it in the wild anyhow but they're
our family they're our kids that's the
last part interesting choice of words
okay
why isn't Jimbo eating out at Jim's
noggin like a pot of honey Jimbo was
born in captivity to a mother who was
also born in captivity and so he really
hasn't had any interaction with other
bears in the wild and in fact he's quite
used to humans instead he's not
threatened by Jim at all and he still
has the hardware to his serious damage
Jimbo weighs 1,400 pounds that's more
than six hundred and thirty kilograms so
a mere SWAT of his arm could break human
bones if he's equipped to survive why
doesn't Jim just set him free if there
was a release Jimbo into the wild he
probably wouldn't do very well because
he hasn't developed the skills of
finding a mate staking out his territory
or associating with conspecifics which
is a fancy way of saying socializing
with other Kodiak bears is Jimbo so
civilized that Jim's never in danger
when Jimmy's interaction with Jimbo it's
important that he remains very calm even
when Jimbo seems to have Jim's head in
his mouth he knows that he needs to
react slowly and calmly but if ever
there's a time not to freak out it's
when your heads in the mouth of a bear
you don't buy good clothes if I choose
one because they don't last long they
have been fatal attacks by Kodiak bears
when they feel threatened or been
surprised by humans in the wild that is
why no one throws surprise parties for
bears